après les difficultés financières de
géronde icap l'avenir s'est éclairci au
mes rentes et une convention vient
d'être signée entre l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines et
l'association pour l'insertion
l'éducation et les soins 51 a fait tout
l'investissement nécessaire sur ce sur
massa mais durant maintenant loue ses
bâtiments un prix attractif puisque
comme je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
100 euros du mètre carré par rapport à
166 euros sur sur le marché et puis va
aider aussi au démarrage dans le
financement ont investi c'est à dire
comme attendent qu'il faut remettre aux
normes à la cuisine c'est la communauté
d'agglo qui va le faire et puis après on
m'a donné trente mille euros au départ
puis 20 milles puis guy milin un
financement sur trois ans avant que le
domaine deviennent autonomes
financièrement le mes rentes et est
depuis 2010 des personnes dépendantes
accueil de jour aide à domicile ou
encore accueil des malades d'alzheimer
une dizaine de partenaires vont
travailler ensemble et là on a
absolument tout ce qui peut se faire sur
tout ce qui peut prendre en charge
vieillissement tout ce qui peut aider à
une meilleure prise en charge du
vieillissement
je pense que là c'est vraiment un c'est
vital la mutualisation le transfert de
compétences transfert d'informations des
expertises c'est vraiment c'est ce qu'il
faut à l'avenir une école d'ergothérapie
doit ouvrir en septembre 2010 8 90
étudiants seront attendus 300 personnes
devraient être accueillis d'ici trois
ans